[Music]
now claire you uh you studied interior
architecture is that right did i read
that correctly yeah
yeah yeah and so um
let me talk to you about how interior
architecture interior the design of
interior spaces
can help save our planet oh that's a big
question how long ago
yes interior architecture so first off
um
when i first first studied started
studying interior architecture people go
oh what interior design
and interior design is part of it
architecture is part of it but it's
really about
constructing the interior of a building
so an architect would generally design
the shell
then an interior architect might come in
and do everything from lighting
decisions to mechanical electrical
engineering as well so sort of
everything else
and when you think about the way the
interior architecture could work we
could think about how to make things
that could change and flex according to
the changing needs of the user
so the way a building is designed the
shell will remain the same and really we
think about embodied carbon i.e the
amount of emissions and energy that have
gone into making anything
you want to keep it for as long as
possible so if we have a building you
don't want to be demolishing it and
starting from scratch
so then an interior architect can come
in and design a space that it can be
mended so for example if the studio you
need to double the space of the studio
you could do it with relative ease
without demolishing something or items
could be movable or dismantlable and you
can change and
you know buildings will change the same
as people's needs will change
and also the materials that you choose
are you choosing materials that fit for
purpose are you choosing materials that
maybe have a recycled content yeah i
know recycling the lowest of the low but
you know if we think about reprocessing
our materials we also need to have an
avenue for that
so if we are you know able to specify or
choose a material that has had a
previous life
then that shows that they have value to
it which means it's more likely to be
collected and more likely to be
reprocessed rather than being
incinerated or binned so all of those
decisions really really can make a
difference
yeah it seems to me that we often don't
think about our spaces
in in that way and yet we you know the
average american house is approaching 3
000 square feet i believe and and we
talked about in our first film
minimalism
with the heat map study where we
basically use 40 of our houses and as
the houses get bigger that percentage
doesn't stay the same it actually
decreases right and so some people use
10 of their house right i remember when
uh i saw dion sanders he built a
a tiny house back house for his mansion
basically but the tiny house he built
was 7 000 square feet wow and
all perspective i guess yeah relative i
suppose right and so
um when we're thinking about our spaces
we're thinking about heating them
cooling them these are all these things
all have an impact on the environment
and uh if we can consider that up front
when we're building a house we're
thinking about the square foot how much
how much space do i actually need
it doesn't mean everyone needs to live
in a tiny house the question is what is
appropriate for you in your life i have
friends who have six kids and so putting
them in a tiny house would be a
nightmare i think right but there are
some people who just
want very little and then they can fit
in a tiny house or a small apartment or
whatever is appropriate for them so
they're not wasting a bunch of space
because
in our society as soon as we get more
space we feel so compelled to fill it
yeah it's like time isn't it you expand
to fill whatever you have so if a task
you know if you've got an hour to do a
10-minute task it's going to take you an
hour to do it
just the way that it is um exactly the
same with spaces but i think what's
interesting about
buildings architecture quite often the
bigger the better the bigger the house
the more successful you are um
and that really is not the case when you
think about i mean in the uk we've got
you know the cost of energy is
increasing dramatically because of
different price caps that are changing
in april this year so there's already
lots of discussion about
how the spaces that people own are going
to cost them more money so we've got
lots of things compounded some because
they're covered and some for different
reasons and i think that's making a lot
of people look at the spaces they have
and think
do i really need to live in such a big
place because you've got to heat it
you've got to maintain it
and when you're building stuff are you
building it to the highest ability to
retain its heat when it's got the heat
renewable energy why are we not having
solar panels if it's suitable for where
you're living
or some form of energy regeneration as
well as you know the landscaping not
just being a tag on but being something
that is integral to the way that our
buildings are designed yeah this is
often where where regulation goes wrong
because in california i heard bill maher
talking about this recently
all of the hoops he had to jump through
in order to get his house to be solar
powered because of all now this is
lobbyists who lobby
the government to prevent you know solar
from being installed easily now it's not
that we don't want any regulations
around that we want people to be safe we
want to be installed correctly but at
the same time we don't want it to be so
difficult that it discourages everyone
from going i mean we live in california
wouldn't it make sense for there to be
way more solar energy here yeah and
what's interesting also about different
renewable energies is the one of the
pushbacks you get is people saying
well the payoff cost so how long it's
going to take to recoup back the
benefits in a monetary sense the cost
that it has
just too big
um but the efficiency of things are
changing every single year so you know
every single time that we go through a
new generation of solar panel or any
kind of renewable energy
it's getting better it's becoming more
efficient they're getting slimmer
they're becoming less obtrusive you can
recess them into roof lines so they
don't have any kind of obstructive
ability to sort of looking at a
beautiful house anymore yeah and it's
also about discovering what is best for
that type of home
or building and exactly where you are in
the world so yeah in the uk we have a
lot of solar but that's not going to be
generating as much power as it would be
on most days in l.a for example so
there's other things that people can
look at as well but having this sort of
the lobbyist of it doesn't look
attractive or it shouldn't be there
we need to think way way beyond that now
we need a suite of solutions not one
silver bullet i like where you're going
with that because what we're talking
about also is eventually as
it gets better it becomes more
aesthetically pleasing as well it may we
may get to a point where
solar is so much more aesthetically
pleasing than a regular roof you're like
oh why would i want a roof when i have
that beautiful new version of of solar
energy it looks stunning and oh by the
way it powers my house for free
basically yeah it might even be films
that go on glass so you can't even see
it that's beautiful or paint that can
help absorb carbon and then you know
create energy from that so there's so
much like mind-blowing research that's
going into this yes um
so yeah so it's something that is coming
more and more and more
and in an exciting way really exciting
way did you enjoy this standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com slash the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free